>> Greg: BEAUTIFUL, BEAUTIFUL.
YES!
YEAH.
ALL RIGHT.
HAPPY WEDNESDAY, EVERYONE.
SO HERE'S SOMETHING INTERESTING
THAT DOESN'T INVOLVE ABORTION OR
WAR.
IT'S A PICTURE OF ME WORKING
OUT.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: KUDOS TO THE GUY
SPOTTING.
THAT REMINDS ME, I HOPE I LOCKED
THE BASEMENT.
SO EVERYONE TALKS ABOUT HOW BAD
SOCIAL MEDIA IS AND YET EVERYONE
USES IT.
IT'S BECOME THE MODERN VERSION
OF SMOKING.
YES, I'VE GOT TO QUIT BUT RIGHT
NOW I JUST CAN'T.
THAT'S ME.
IT'S THE SAME PROBLEM I HAVE
WITH MAKING BRIAN STELTER FAT
JOKES.
I CAN'T CONTROL MYSELF.
IT'S LIKE BRIAN STELTER AT
KRISPY KREME.
SEE, I DIDN'T EVEN KNOW I SAID
THAT.
AND I RARELY FEEL BETTER AFTER
SCROLLING THROUGH ON LINE STUFF
AND I ALWAYS TELL PEOPLE TO
SPEND LESS TIME DOING IT YET
THERE I AM LATE AT NIGHT
SNEAKING A SOCIAL MEDIA PUFF AND
LIKE SMOKING IT USUALLY MAKES MY
BLOOP GO UP.
NOW I TELL MYSELF THAT SOCIAL
MEDIA'S A HARMLESS DRINKING
PARTNER AND I HAVE COMPANY BUT I
DON'T HAVE TO PUT OUT CHEESE OR
CRACKERS OR AS MSNBCCALLS IT.
CHEESE AND WHITE PEOPLE.
HOWEVER HOW WOULD I BE AS A
PERSON IF I STOPPED EVEN FOR A
WEEK?
WELL, A NEW STUDY REVEALED WHAT
CAN HAPPEN IF YOU STOP USING
SOCIAL MEDIA.
YOU DIE.
I'M KIDDING, YOU DON'T DIE.
IN FACT, QUITE THE OPPOSITE.
YOU LIVE.
A NEW STUDY THAT AVOIDS SOCIAL
MEDIA PLATFORMS JUST ONE WEEK,
THAT'S THE WEEKEND PLUS FIVE
KAT, SIGNIFICANTLY IMPROVES A
PERSON'S WELL-BEING REDUCING
BOTH ANXIETY AND DEDEPRESSION.
IF THERE WAS A PILL THAT HAD THE
SAME EFFECT IN ONE WEEK YOU
WOULD TAKE IT.
WE USED TO CALL THOSE QUAALUDES,
RIGHT DAY BEGAN.
>> Dagen: YEAH
>> Greg: BUT SOCIAL MEDIA ISN'T
SOMETHING YOU CAN TAKE.
LIKE THE PRESIDENT'S TEETH AT
BEDTIME, IT'S SOMETHING YOU HAVE
TO REMOVE.
AND THAT'S HARDER.
IN THIS STUDY RESEARCHERS FROM
THE UNIVERSITY OF BATH, WHICH IS
WAY BETTER THAN YOUR NAL STATE
COLLEGE FOUND MOST SOCIAL MEDIA
CONSUMERS SPEND NINE HOURS A
WEEK ON LINE WHETHER SCROLLING
THROUGH INSTAGRAM, FACEBOOK,
TWITTER OR MY FAVORITE WEB SITE
MATURE MILFS WITH CLUBBED FEET.
TO FIND OUT WHAT MIGHT HAPPEN
WHEN YOU CUT BACK, RESEARCHERS
HAD OVER 150 PEOPLE BETWEEN THE
AGES OF 18 AND 72 DO JUST THAT.
YEAH, EVEN 72 YEAR OLD.
WHAT ARE THEY DOING ON LINE?
ANYBODY SEEN GRAMMY?
YEAH, SHE'S TEACHING PEOPLE HOW
TO STRAIN PASTA THROUGH AN OLD
PAIR OF NYLONS ON TIK TOK.
SEEN IT 17 TIMES.
THEN THEY COMPARE THEIR NORMAL
USE KNOWLEDGE TO A WEEK WHEN
THEY WERE ON LINE THREE MINUTES
A DAY WHICH IS THE SAME AMOUNT
THEY SPENT ON RESEARCHING.
AND LIKE JESSIE AFTER HIS RECENT
HAIR TRANSPLANT DISGUISED AS A
BACK SURGERY.
>> Tyrus: COLD BLOODED.
>> Greg: THE RESULTS WERE
ASTONISHING.
AFTER JUST ONE WEEK WITHOUT
SOCIAL MEDIA, THERE WERE
DRAMATIC IMPROVEMENTS IN
WELL-BEING ACROSS THE BOARD.
SO WHY IS THIS IMPORTANT?
WELL, SOCIAL MEDIA AGAIN, LIKE
SMOKING, IS SOMETHING WE DO
ALMOST WITHOUT THINKING.
SOMETIMES IT'S THE FIRST THING
WE DO WHEN WE WAKE UP, THE LAST
THING WE DO BEFORE WE SLEEP OR
RIGHT AFTER SEX AT A TRUCK STOP.
IT REALLY HAS BECOME A TWO PACK
A DAY HABIT UNFILTERED AND
CLOGGING OUR BRAIN WITH TAR AND
SELFIES.
RESEARCH DOCUMENTS DOZENS OF
HARMFUL EFFECTS FROM BEING ON
LINE CONSTANTLY NOT INCLUDING
THE POTENTIAL OF RUNNING INTO
ANTHONY WEINER.
BUT THERE'S MORE TO IT THAN
THAT.
AND IT'S SOMETHING OVERLOOKED BY
ALL THE RESEARCHERS.
IT'S THAT WE HUMANS CAN ONLY
FOCUS ON ONE THING AT A TIME.
GO AHEAD.
TRY TO HOLD TWO THOUGHTS IN YOUR
HEAD.
I'LL WAIT.
SEE, IT'S IMPOSSIBLE.
BUT YOU ALREADY KNEW THAT.
FOR EXAMPLE, ONE DAY YOU COULD
BE IN A GREAT MOOD, SUN IS
SHINING, WORK IS GREAT, GOT
PLANS FOR THE WEEKEND.
BUT IF YOU GET IN A TIFF WITH A
SPOUSE IT ALL DISAPPEARS, IT'S
GONE AND ALL YOU THINK ABOUT IS
THAT ONE THING.
THAT'S WHAT SOCIAL MEDIA DOES.
IT CAN INTRODUCE ONE DISTURBING
THOUGHT THAT MUSCLES EVERYTHING
ELSE OUT AND THAT'S HOW IT RUINS
YOUR DAY AND CREATES SLEEPLESS
TONIGHT.
IT CAN BE A DISTRACTION LIKE AN
INSULT FROM A STRANGER SOMEBODY
YOU DON'T EVEN KNOW BUT IT'S ALL
IT TAKES.
IT'S CREATED AGGRESSIVE STIMULI
THAT WE AS HUMANS ARE NOT
EVOLVED YET TO HANDLE.
OUR BRAINS AND YOUNG BRAINS
ESPECIALLY, WE CAN'T TELL THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN WHAT'S WORTH
THINKING ABOUT AND WHAT ISN'T
WORTH THINKING ABOUT.
ALL YOU END UP DOING IS THINKING
ABOUT WHATEVER ENTERS YOUR
MENTAL CRAWL SPACE LAST.
NOT GOOD.
SO MAYBE IT'S TIME TO TAKE A
BREAK, ESPECIALLY IF JUST
STOPPING FOR ONE WEEK HAS SUCH
POSITIVE BENEFITS.
WHY DON'T WE TRY IT?
I MEAN, WHAT'S THE WORST THAT
COULD HAPPEN?
>> YOU KNOW, GREG IS RIGHT FOR
ONCE.
I'M WASTING TIME CHECKING THINGS
ON TWITTER AND INSTAGRAM AND
FACEBOOK AND ONLY FANS AND EVEN,
UGHH, LINKED IN.
IT'S TIME FOR ME TO START
LIVING.
♪♪
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S
GUESTS!
HE'S SO SHARP GILLETTE WANTS TO
TRADEMARK HIM.
FORMER WHITE HOUSE PRESS
SECRETARY AND FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR ARI FLEISCHER!
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: SHE'S SO SOUTHERN SHE
BRUSHES HER TEETH WITH GRITS FOX
BUSINESS ANCHOR DAGEN McDOWELL!
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: SHE BELIEVES THE GRASS
IS ALWAYS GREENER WHEN YOU SELL
IT TO COLLEGE KIDS.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR KAT TIMPF!
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: AND THE FIRE DEPARTMENT
CALLS HIM WHEN A CAT IS STUCK IN
A TREE.
MY MASTER SIDE KICK AND THE NWA
WORLD TELEVISION CHAMPION TYRUS!
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: ARI, UNLIKE THE REST OF
US YOU SEEM TO BE A GROWNUP.
YOU HAVE A SUIT.
YOU'VE HAD REAL JOBS.
DO YOU LET CERTAIN THINGS ENTER
YOUR HEAD.
I THINK PEOPLE WILL OFTEN LIE
AND SAY, OH, I DON'T TAKE
ANYTHING ON LINE SERIOUSLY.
OH, I DON'T READ MY MENTIONS.
OH, I DON'T -- BUT EVERYBODY
DOES.
AND THEN IF THERE'S ONE THING
THAT GETS IN YOUR HEAD, IT
CROWDS OUT EVERYTHING ELSE.
IT PUSHES ALL THE FUN STUFF AND
IT'S JUST THIS ONE THOUGHT OF
SOMEBODY SAYING ARI FLEISCHER'S
A BIG FAT JERK.
AND YOU'RE NOT BY THE WAY, JUST
HYPOTHETICAL
>> Ari: FIRST OF ALL, THIS IS A
RENTAL SO I NEED TO GET THROUGH
THE SHOW FAST BECAUSE I GOT TO
GET IT BACK IN TIME.
BUT HAVING WORKED AT THE WHITE
HOUSE, YOU REALLY DO LEARN TO
BLOCK STUFF OUT.
I LIKE SOCIAL MEDIA.
I LIKE TO LOOK AT IT.
BUT I REALLY DO HAVE THE ABILITY
TO GO THIS IS NONSENSE, THIS IS
NONSENSE, THIS IS NONSENSE,
WHERE'S THE YANKEES SCORE.
THERE ARE JUST SOME THINGS THAT
ARE IMPORTANT AND OTHER THINGS
YOU JUST KNOW IS PEOPLE
SCREAMING AND I HAVE A GOOD
ABILITY
>> Greg: DO YOU HAVE KIDS?
>> Ari: THE ABILITY TO HEAR
PEOPLE SCREAMING?
YES
>> Greg: DO YOU WORRY ABOUT THEM
THEN?
>> Ari: MY KIDS AREN'T ON IT
>> Greg: THAT'S IMPOSSIBLE
>> Kat: THAT'S WHAT YOU THINK
>> Ari: NO, NO
>> Greg: WHAT'S YOUR KID'S FIRST
NAME?
RIGHT HERE
>> Ari: HER FAKE NAME?
>> Greg: YEAH.
>> Ari: NO, IT'S JUST NOT THEIR
THING.
THEY ARE ON IT A LITTLE BIT THEY
LOOK AT STUFF BUT I KNOW THEY'RE
NOT DOING WHAT THEY'RE SUPPOSED
TO BE DOING BECAUSE I CHECK
>> Greg: KUDOS TO THEM I JUST
DON'T BELIEVE IT.
MY PARENTS NEVER KNEW I HAD A
STACK OF PLAY BOYS UNDER MY
MATTRESS UNTIL ONE DAY THEY
DISAPPEARED.
DIDN'T SEE MY DAD FOR A WEEK.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: DAGAN DO YOU KNOW WHAT
I'M TALKING ABOUT?
DO YOU LOOK AT SOCIAL MEDIA
BEFORE YOU GO TO BED.
IS IT DESTRUCTIVE?
>> Dagen: NO, I PREFER SOCIAL
MEDIA TO REAL LIFE
>> Greg: REALLY.
>> Dagen: YEAH, REALITY IS WAY
OVERRATED.
I'M NOT EXAGGERATING.
COMING TO WORK THIS MORNING, NEW
YORK CITY, I BUMP INTO A GUY
WEARING A FUZZY BEAR MASK RIDING
A BIKE CARRYING WHAT LOOKED LIKE
A HOMEMADE SWORD.
AND ON SOCIAL MEDIA I DON'T RUN
THE RISK OF ACTUALLY GETTING
MAIMED AND HAVING HIM TAKE MY
HAND AS A SOUVENIR.
OR ON SOCIAL MEDIA, YOU KNOW
WHAT DEPRESSION IS?
WALKING OUTSIDE AND THE BRIGHT
SUNLIGHT HITTING THE CELLULITE.
I WANT TO HIDE FOR DAYS.
ON SOCIAL MEDIA I CAN FILTER
THESE HALF CENTURY OLD GAMS.
THEY LOOK LIKE THEY BELONG TO A
DUDE.
>> Greg: A VERY SEXY DUDE,
THOUGH.
>> Dagen: YOU DON'T HAVE TO
BRUSH YOUR TEETH ON SOCIAL MEDIA
AND ALSO EVERY BABY'S CUTE.
EVERY BABY IS ADORABLE AND WE
ALL HAVE FAMILY AND FRIENDS WHO
HAVE HAD BABIES THAT LOOKED LIKE
DANNY DEVito AND YOU HAVE TO
LAUGH AND IGNORE IT AND JUST
PRAY THAT IT GROWS OUT OF IT
>> Greg: YOU REMIND ME I CALL
THIS THE DORIAN GRAY EFFECT THAT
IF WE GET INTO THE WORLD OF
VIRTUAL REALITY, EVERYBODY IS
GOING TO BE AWESOME IN VIRTUAL
REALITY AS THEY GET BIGGER AND
FATTER AND GROSSER BECAUSE
THEY'RE NOT GOING ANYWHERE.
SO IT WILL BE LIKE, IT'S THE
PAINTING THAT AGES WHILE -- IS
THAT NORMAL?
YOU KNOW, THAT WAS JUST AN
ANALOGY AND I'M JUST GOING TO
SHUT UP.
THAT WENT OVER WELL.
I JUST SIT HERE AWKWARDLY?
>> Tyrus: WE ARE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: DON'T YOU UNDERSTAND
WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT?
>> Tyrus: WE DON'T EVEN KNOW WHO
YOU'RE TALKING TO.
I MEAN, IT'S GOTTEN TO THE POINT
WHERE YOU JUST TALK IN ONE OF
OUR DIRECTION AND ONE OF US
FEELS IT
>> Kat: YEAH.
>> Tyrus: YOU WANT TO TAKE THIS
ONE
>> Kat: I WAS KIND OF LIKE I'M
GOING TO WAIT UNTIL IT BECOMES
MY PROBLEM.
>> Greg: SO WHAT DO YOU THINK
TYRUS?
>> Tyrus: THERE WE GO.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
UNFORTUNATELY I AGREE WITH YOU,
SOCIAL MEDIA HAS BECOME A BIGGER
MONSTER THAN ANYONE CAN DEAL
WITH.
I CAN'T STAND IT AND MOST OF THE
PEOPLE THAT I KNOW ARE ON IT ARE
LIVING HORRIBLE PERSONAL LIVES.
BUT THEIR SOCIAL MEDIA IS
PHENOMENAL.
LIKE THEIR PICTURES ARE ALWAYS
SMILING, THEY'RE ALWAYS MADLY IN
LOVE AND THEY SAY THINGS LIKE
FOUR HOURS SINCE I'VE SEEN MY
HUSBAND.
OH, NO, WHAT WILL I DO?
YOU KNOW, AND DEEP DOWN THEY
HAVEN'T SPOKE IN WEEKS IN REAL
LIFE.
SO I GET IT YOU KNOW WHAT DAGAN
SAYS MAN, IT'S A GREAT COVER BUT
I'M LUCKY I HAVE TWO AND THEY'RE
CONNECTED, TWITTER AND INSTAGRAM
ARE CONNECTED SO I ONLY HAVE TO
DEAL WITH ONE AND ON MINE I LOOK
AT IT TWO HOURS A WEEK SO I
GUESS I'M WINNING.
MY KIDS I'M CONSTANTLY SNATCHING
PHONES AND IPADS.
THEY CAN MAKE ONE OUT OF STICKS.
LIKE THE GENIUS BEHIND GETTING
ON LINE AND BLOCKING LIKE -- I
HOPE YOU'RE RIGHT BUT MINE'S
SEVEN AND I CAN'T LEAVE ANY
ELECTRONICS.
SHE CAN TAKE THE MICROWAVE INTO
A SOCIAL MEDIA OUTPOST.
SHE'S ALWAYS ON IT
>> Greg: THAT'S AMAZING.
CAM I NOTICE ON THE REELS THE
INSTAGRAM REELS THE CRAZY FACE.
LIKE I'M HAVING SUCH A GOOD TIME
I'M CRAZY.
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT
>> Kat: YES, I DO ACTUALLY
>> Greg: THEY'RE LIKE LOOK AT MY
BABY, THIS IS SUCH A GREAT BABY
>> Kat: THERE'S ALL DIFFERENT
SUB SETS OF THAT.
LIKE SINGLE MOM BUT I'M STILL
REALLY HAPPY FACE I THINK IS
WHAT MOST OF IT IS.
I THINK I'M FINE WITH SOCIAL
MEDIA.
I DON'T KNOW.
LIKE IT WASN'T AROUND WHEN I WAS
LIKE IN HIGH SCHOOL AND THERE'S
A LOT OF TALK ABOUT, YOU KNOW,
TEEN-AGERS AND INSTAGRAM MAKING
THEM MASSIVELY DEPRESSED AND I'M
SURE THAT IF IT WAS AROUND WHEN
I WAS IN HIGH SCHOOL INSTAGRAM
WOULD HAVE MADE ME MASSIVELY
DEPRESSED SO IT WASN'T SO I HAD
TO GET MASSIVELY DEPRESSED ABOUT
OTHER STUFF, WHICH IS WHAT I
WOULD DO ANYWAYS
>> Greg: THAT'S THE POINT YOU
CAN'T STUDY TEEN-AGERS BECAUSE
THEY'RE DEPRESSED ABOUT
EVERYTHING.
>> Tyrus: WE DO HAVE TO BE FAIR
ABOUT SOCIAL MEDIA,